-In a few minutes,
we are going to talk
to Connecticut Senator
Chris Murphy,
which I am very grateful for,
because he gave
a very powerful speech
on the Senate floor yesterday
demanding that his colleagues
take action.
And I was thankful
for those words
because among many other things,
it reminded us
that we can't become numb.
Because what is happening right
now does not have to happen.
It is not inevitable.
It is a choice,
a choice that our leaders
and the powerful forces
behind them have made
and are continuing
to make every day
that they refuse
to do anything at all
that could make these
horrific events less likely.
America has more guns
than people.
We have more mass shootings by
far than any other peer nations.
Those two things
are obviously related.
So now to talk a little bit more
about how we got to a place
where those two things
can be true,
it is time
for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Applause ]
Entrenched, powerful forces
have perpetrated a monumental,
decades-long fraud in convincing
large numbers of people
that it is their constitutional
right to own arsenals
and military-grade weaponry.
And they've invested
large sums in convincing people
that that made-up right --
a right five Republican justices
essentially invented
out of whole cloth
not that long ago --
is constantly under threat.
And to be clear,
that's not just my opinion.
I'm not a constitutional
scholar.
I think that's clear.
Constitutional scholars
do not have tiny figurines
of Andy Samberg on their desk
that say, "My doink fell off."
I'm not saying
they don't have them.
I'm just saying if they do,
they're kept safely in a drawer.
So, I didn't just come up with
the take that the unregulated
right to own military-grade
weaponry is a fraud.
on my own --
it was the opinion
of former Supreme Court
Chief Justice Warren Burger,
a conservative who said
this in 1991.
-If I were writing
the Bill of Rights now,
there wouldn't be any such thing
as the Second Amendment.
-Which says...
-That a well regulated militia,
being necessary for the defense
of the state,
the people's rights
to bear arms.
This has been the subject
of one of the greatest
pieces of fraud --
I repeat the word fraud --
on the American public
by special interest groups
that I have ever seen
in my lifetime.
Now, just look at those words.
There are only three lines
to that amendment.
"A well regulated militia."
If the militia, which was going
to be the state army,
was going to be well regulated,
why shouldn't 16 and 17 and 18
or any other age persons
be regulated in the use of arms
the way an automobile
is regulated?
-First of all, it's a shock just
to see a conservative justice
say something in public without
sneering like the villain
from every '80s teen comedy.
Second, he's right.
The words "well-regulated" are
right there in the amendment.
There is no mystery.
It's not Wordle
or the New York Times
Spelling Bee.
We don't have to guess --
which, by the way,
it's what I do, guys.
After I get the easy ones,
I just start
typing in fake words
and hoping they're real.
Moaxy?
Is moaxy a word?
Let me try 30 more times.
[ Laughter ]
The idea that
the Second Amendment
guarantees an individual's
unregulated right to own
an arsenal of military-grade
weaponry is so insane
and was shrugged off
as ridiculous for so long.
Then, in 1982,
Senate Republicans
went to the absurd lengths
of issuing a report that claimed
to have discovered
"clear and long-lost proof
that the Second Amendment
was intended as an individual
right of the American citizen
to keep and carry arms."
It is absolutely insane
that Republicans claim
to have found long-lost proof
that changed the meaning
of a document written in 1787,
in 1982, which means --
definitely means
one of them had just seen
"Raiders of the Lost Ark"
and then said,
"You know, sometimes
people find old [bleep]
I'm just saying."
I mean, how'd it go?
Did Nicolas Cage find a secret
Post-it Note hidden
inside the Liberty Bell?
We were so focused on the crack,
we never looked inside!
[ Laughter ]
But that should give you an idea
of how preposterous
and unhinged this whole idea is.
The side that claims to care
about the plain language
of the Constitution
and the original meaning
of the Founding Fathers
had to pretend
to unearth some secret,
hidden proof
that the Second Amendment
actually means
something completely different
from what it obviously says,
which is totally divorced
from how other sane countries
deal with these kind of horrors.
Australia, the UK,
New Zealand, Norway --
they've all responded
to mass shootings
with stricter gun laws
or campaigns
to confiscate or buy back guns.
And those laws have worked
because again,
there is an obvious correlation
between how many guns
we have in this country
and how many gun deaths we have.
And by the way,
when local governments
have tried gun buyback programs
on a small scale here in the US,
they've often been successful.
In fact, just a few days ago,
the police department
in Sacramento
held a gun buyback event in
exchange for $50 gas gift cards.
The event, which was supposed
to last for five hours,
got more takers than expected.
The department announced
just 45 minutes into the event
that it had exhausted
its supply of gift cards
due to overwhelming response.
I'm not surprised.
You know what I'd give up for
a $50 gas gift card right now?
Half a tank?!
[ Laughter ]
That's why I dress
like this right now.
I gave all my suits back
as part of a buyback program,
and now I don't have to pay
for gas for another week.
I also gave up haircuts,
which is why I'm now
on an ongoing mission
to get cast
in the next Marvel movie
as Old Loki.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I think I can do it.
Because I look, like...
5 to 10 months older
than Tom Hiddleston.
[ Laughter ]
But even more revealing than
the success of the event itself
were the reasons people gave
for turning in these guns.
Among other reasons, community
members most commonly cited
a lack of experience
or knowledge with firearms,
lack of knowledge
of the legality of firearms,
or an inability to safely store
the firearms
as the main reasons for
participating in the exchange.
It turns out some people
don't even want these guns
and would like
to get rid of them.
Imagine if we launch
a national campaign like that
or like what Australia did
in the '90s
when it confiscated
650,000 guns,
and as a result,
gun deaths plummeted.
Of course, in Australia they
didn't give out gas gift cards,
they gave out Foster's
because, you know,
it's Australian for beer.
Real talk, though --
they don't drink Foster's
in Australia.
"Foster's --
it's Australian for beer"
is just a marketing lie
they invented
to try to sell it to us,
and they used Crocodile Dundee
to do it.
I trusted you, Croc!
I trusted you,
and you lied to me.
"Fosters -- it's Australian
for beer" would be like
if I were in a commercial
on Australian TV
where I said, "Arby's --
it's American for steak."
[ Laughter ]
Or if Republican senators
said they claimed
to have discovered
clear and long-lost proof
that the Second Amendment said
everyone is allowed
to have all the guns they want,
in that it's obvious bull[bleep]
because again, as we've seen,
gun safety measures
like assault weapons bans
and gun buyback programs
have worked.
They have worked
in other countries.
When we've tried them,
they've worked here, too.
Our gun production and ownership
rates are simply off the charts,
incomparable
to any other nation on Earth.
And as a result,
so are our gun deaths.
It's within our power
to stop this,
and allowing these massacres
to continue is,
in fact, a choice,
as Connecticut Senator
Chris Murphy
said in a speech
on the Senate floor yesterday.
-What are we doing?
Why do you spend all this time
running for
the United States Senate?
Why do you go through all
the hassle of getting this job,
of putting yourself
in a position of authority?
If your answer is that
as this slaughter increases,
as our kids run for their lives,
we do nothing.
What are we doing?
Why are you here?
I'm here on this floor to beg --
to literally get down
on my hands and knees
and beg my colleagues.
Find a path forward here.
Work with us
to find a way to pass laws
that make this less likely.
-This is a moment, if you are
a person in a position of power,
to ask yourself what
you're doing to stop this.
Because he's right.
Why are you there?
Why else are you
in the United States Senate?
Unless it's to raise money
and give speeches
and dole out favors
and ride that secret little
train in the Capitol basement
that looks like
the railroad to Disneyland,
except instead of dropping you
off at the Magic Kingdom,
it brings you
to Lindsey Graham's office.
[ As Graham ]
My office is like a castle,
in that my meemaw calls me
a little Prince Charming.
[ Normal voice ]
And yet, maddeningly,
there are those who claim
to support
popular gun safety measures
but aren't actually
willing to use their power
to get those measures passed,
like West Virginia
Senator Joe Manchin.
CNN reported yesterday
that Manchin says he would do
"anything I can" to move common
sense gun legislation forward,
but still refused to eliminate
the filibuster
to get gun legislation
through the Senate.
Then you're not willing
to do anything you can!
It's like if you told
your spouse you're willing to do
anything to clean the dishes
except get up from the couch.
"I can do it from here
if you tie a sponge
to a long stick."
[ Laughter ]
If you're willing to live
with these horrors,
then just say that.
Just say you're willing to.
But don't hide behind
a bull[bleep] procedural rule
that, by the way,
is not in the Constitution
and didn't even exist when
the Senate was created anyway.
You guys all act
like the Constitution
has an entire section
on the filibuster,
when the word isn't even
so much as mentioned once.
Maybe we need to get Nick Cage
to burst into Manchin's office
with a secret piece
of parchment screaming, "Joe!
I found a note from John Adams
in the Lincoln Memorial's taint!
He said the filibuster
is bull[bleep]"
No, of course, Nick Cage
would never agree to do that.
But what about someone who does
an excellent impression of him?
[ Laughter ]
Just think about it.
And by the way,
this is the same Senate
that moved with the speed
of a Saturn V rocket
to get Supreme Court justices
more security
when some people were picketing
outside their homes.
So that should give you
a sense of their priorities.
When they do want
to protect someone,
they're capable
of doing it quickly.
And while the Manchins and
Mitch McConnells of the world
are offering their empty words
and refusing to take action,
the most depraved people
in our politics are suggesting
that instead of doing
the obvious thing
that many other countries
have done successfully,
which is to simply pass laws
regulating the number of guns
in the country
and the ability
to easily get them,
we should instead arm teachers
and essentially turn schools
into fortified military bases.
-The most effective tool
for keeping kids safe
is armed law enforcement
on the campus.
-People, retired military,
retired law enforcement
outside the perimeter
of every school in the country.
They can donate their time.
They can --
We can offer them tax breaks,
no income tax in the state,
no income tax federally,
10 hours a week.
And we could have every school
in America covered.
-We have to harden these targets
so no one can get in, ever,
except through one entrance.
-What we need to do
is utilize smart technology.
That's what's needed.
We need to install man traps.
This is something
we've discussed in the past,
back in 2018 -- I checked.
Man traps,
a series of interlocking doors
at the school entrance
that are triggered
by a tripwire.
-We can't stop bad people
from doing bad things.
They're gonna violate
murder laws,
they're not gonna follow
gun laws.
I've never understood
that argument.
But we are -- we can harden
these schools.
We can create points of access
that are difficult
to get through.
We can potentially arm
and prepare and train teachers
and other administrators
to respond quickly.
-Are you out of your
[bleep] mind?
You guys want to turn schools
into maximum security prisons
with man traps and tripwires
and teachers carrying guns?
If these people had their way,
everything would be a scene
out of [bleep] "RoboCop."
There are truly no words
for how grotesque this is.
They want to arm teachers
and yet they're not even willing
to throw enough money at schools
to get them history books
that don't end with the fall
of the Berlin Wall.
And that's...
[ Applause ]
And that's, right there...
[ Applause continues ]
Kids, that's how Ronald Reagan
saved democracy.
If you want to know
what happened after that,
get into college.
And to the people
who cynically parrot
the mindless talking point
that advocates for gun reform
are somehow politicizing this --
what else?
What else is politics for?
It's a crisis.
And this is what
our political system
is supposed to do --
address the crisis.
If that's all you can muster
in the wake of this horror,
that tired, empty mantra,
then you need to look inward
because we can --
we can do something.
We know from our experience,
our own experience,
and from the experiences
of other countries,
it's possible.
It has not always been
like this.
It doesn't always have to be
We can change things.
And if you're a person in a
position of power, you must act.
Because if you choose
to spend this moment
in the wake of this horror
using your power to do nothing,
then you are a...
-Fraud.
I repeat the word fraud.
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
God's Love We Deliver
cooks and brings
over 2 million meals a year
to men, women, and children
living with HIV/AIDS, cancer,
and other serious illnesses
and they need your help
now more than ever.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe. Get vaccinated.
We love you.